what's your guys like uh uh thoughts on
the past year
like you have a good year
i had a good year
yeah say it again we're doing
predictions
yeah predictions that's not what i asked
what did you ask i asked what your
thought was on the last year like i had
a great year probably one of my favorite
things was moving to miami and out of
new york city there we go see that's
what i was looking for yeah i i
appreciate that we don't live in new
york anymore yeah but you want to know
what i really think or do you just want
to know like what the pc answer is
but
i want to know what you really think
let's hear it
my entire idea is just uh
i think that the virus exposed the shams
of society
from various institutions
to people who are completely full of
[ __ ] to what ultimately is important in
life and also it really made people
focus on uh what they wanted to do with
their time so i think it was um
obviously a
very very uh tough time for a lot of
people both economically and also and
also the public health stuff uh some
people are still feeling the effects of
it so i don't want to um uh kind of
minimize what that uh the negative side
effects of some of this are but i do
think that for a certain portion of the
population it made them refocus it made
them understand what was important to
them it made them make uh pretty
significant life decisions right that
ended up uh uh doing things so whether
it's moving whether it's uh getting
married whether it is uh maybe switching
jobs maybe um you know
spending time doing something that they
weren't doing before self-improvement
whatever i do think that like that's
like the positive view of the last uh
really two years um but at the same time
like i think that there's absolute
carnage in uh the economy and i think
that uh the mainstream media really
hasn't covered a lot of it because it's
much easier to just talk about the stock
assets right like oh stock market's up
you know crypto's up whatever but when
you actually go and you look the people
who have the least amount of coverage
the people who have the um kind of least
uh amount of voice especially on the
internet they're the people who are
getting hurt the most yeah so if you go
and you actually look at a lot of this
even though we see people who are
getting higher wages or hourly rates or
whatever like they're still in a really
really tough situation and so i think
that uh that's always like the kind of
silent uh impact of these situations is
that just those stories don't get
covered nearly as much as like oh look
at this billionaire made a bunch of
money or look at this company went
public or look at this you know uh
person who uh uh who did a b or c uh or
stocks went up or whatever we just don't
talk about you know what about the
let's use an example what about the
person who uh is a single mom that works
two jobs that even though she got a
let's say 10 raise
her her rent went up the cost of
groceries go up and also while all
that's happened she has to deal with how
the hell now my kid is uh at home and
has to do zoom classes uh and i gotta go
to work and you know there's other
complexities that enter into life and
like that story doesn't get told yeah
right and so it's like a lot of things
that i think people took for granted
over the last two years uh when you get
like literally and it sounds crazy but
like your kids going to school means
that during that time somebody is
watching your kid educating them cetera
and you can go and work or do whatever
if all of a sudden that gets taken away
well like what happens to that person
right and what happens if there can't
work from home if they're still required
to come into work
like just that alone is a huge
complexity that if that's not the
situation you're in it's easy to forget
that literally millions of people that's
what they're dealing with